all right welcome to hannity tonight in
just a moment an important message for
dr anthony fauci who seems to value his
precious little ego more than you the
american people also tonight biden's
borders are kamala harris apparently
unwilling or unable to determine the
root causes of illegal immigration so we
did her job for her by sending our own
sarah carter to central america where
she uncovered a shocking migrant
smuggling operation we have that
exclusive report straight ahead
but first tonight a big announcement
from the white house a brand new
generous 300 billion dollar handout to
ivy league graduates sociology majors
and many other irresponsible men and
women
that racked up massive student loans and
no longer feel like paying them back
isn't that nice now biden is calling it
a loan forgiveness program in reality it
should be called the biden bribery and
vote buying act of 2022 all paid for by
you the hard-working american people and
truck drivers and farmers and welders
and small business owners and members of
the military and waiters and waitresses
and bartenders and taxpayers that never
went to college or maybe they already
paid off their student loans well now
they're going to be on the hook for the
loans taken out by what a harvard grad
who majored in what gender studies now
according to legend robin hood took from
the rich and gave to the poor but in the
washington swamp joseph robinette biden
well he takes from the poor in the
middle class in order to bail out the
elites because they're going to be the
beneficiaries here now this massive 300
billion dollar payout is either going to
be paid for with your tax dollars or by
simply printing more money in other
words inflation is about to get even
worse now this from a guy who calls
himself middle class joe amtrak joe now
ultimately democrats they don't care
about the middle class they don't care
about your hard work or fiscal
responsibility they only care about
paying off their woke base oh in just
what a little over two months before an
election now don't take my word for it
just listen to this exchange between
senator elizabeth warren and a voter
from a campaign event this is in 2020.
take a look at this
my daughter's getting out of school i've
saved all my money she doesn't have any
student loans
am i going to get my money back
so you're going to pay for people who
didn't save any money and those of us
that did the right thing get screwed
of
bought a car went on vacations i saved
my money we did the right thing and we
get screwed
we did the right thing and we get
screwed he's pretty much right now when
confronted with the cold hard truth
elizabeth warren she's pretty much
speechless but make no mistake there's
nothing fair there's nothing equitable
about this handout and by the way it
does zero to address the root cause of
student debt for example tuition at
harvard costs around 55 grand a year now
the school also receives
millions and millions and millions from
the state and federal government along
with millions more in tax deductible
donations now harvard takes in so much
excess cash that it has now accumulated
a massive
50 billion dollar endowment 50 billion
and it's not just harvard it's colleges
and universities all over america they
are swimming in cash and yet every year
the cost of tuition goes up and up and
up more than double the rate of
inflation now because the federal
government guarantees every student loan
colleges have zero incentive to reduce
costs or implement something called a
budget they always get paid and this
latest three hundred dollar bailout and
handout is no different now there's one
glaring problem with biden's academic
payout according to speaker pelosi maybe
for the first time in my life i agree
with her she says the president has no
authority at all whatsoever to forgive
loans now pay close attention it may be
the one time nancy pelosi was right in
her political career take a look people
think that the president of the united
states has the power
for debt forgiveness
he does not he can postpone he can delay
but he does not have that power that
would has to be an act of congress
and um
i i i don't even like to call it
forgiveness because that
implies a transgression it's not to be
forgiven get
just freeing people from those
obligations
no power for debt
uh what did he say forgiveness oh no
power at all that should be congress's
role now pelosi for the first time in
our life is probably right with biden's
loan scheme well is it ever going to see
the light of day here now i'm sure she's
had a change of political heart this is
an election year it's called that's
right an election year conversion hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else